this question is going to use what we
know about applications of
differentiation but it's going to kind
of do it in a reverse order to what we
normally expect so you can see the
question here says find B and C these
are our unknowns so our final lines of
our question will say answer rather is B
equals this C equals that that's our
target if they give you this particular
function let's just highlight that
equation there and they tell you so this
is a condition that applies to this
function they tell you that there are
particular stationary points and they
give you the locations of those
stationary points once at x equals
negative two one is x equals four so
we're more used to being given a
function and then saying okay well where
are the stationary points go and find
them get me an x coordinate getting your
y coordinate and then potentially
determine their nature this question
clearly you know shares a lot of pieces
of that you have a function you're
connecting two stationary points but
rather than the stationary points being
the answer that we're searching for they
actually form the basis of the question
so we know the stationary points and
we're going to use that information
supplied to us to work out something
about the function namely that this B
and C these two coefficients that appear
right here we don't know what they are
they're constants of some kind but we
don't know what their values are and
we'll use the stationary points supplied
to us to actually determine what they're
equal to so being that this is just like
every other question to do with
stationary points where you get given a
function the first thing I'm going to do
is differentiate so we're going to get
dy on DX it's a polynomial so pretty
comfortable dealing with these guys it's
going to be by the looks of things 3x
squared plus 2 BX plus C and then when
you differentiate that 5 constant on the
end it becomes 0 so I have my derivative
now okay now if I'm told by the question
that this function has stationary points
at x equals negative 2 and x equals 4
then that means when i take those
x-values and substitute them into this
particular derivative right here then I
should get a certain value namely since
they're stationary points the derivative
should be equal to 0
for those particular x-values so I'm
gonna state that to show what my working
means when x equals negative 2 and when
it's equal to 4 the derivative equals 0
that's kind of the definition of a
stationary point and once I do
once I note this I can actually form two
equations one for x equals negative 2
and 1 for x equals 4 so let me show show
that happening over here and over here
I'm gonna substitute x equals negative 2
into the derivative so that gives me 3
lots of negative 2 squared plus 2b
remember B is that unknown so I'm just
gonna leave it there okay
multiplied by negative 2 because I'm
substituting that for X plus 6 so I've
done all the substitution that's dy/dx
for this particular x value but I know
because there's a stationary point there
that that means the whole derivative
will equal 0 I can tidy this up a teeny
bit negative 2 all squared will be 4 so
3 times 4 is 12
I've got to be times negative 2 so watch
out for that negative there there will
be a 4 and then plus C equals 0 so this
is a statement that I know about B and C
but it's not enough information I need
this other stationary point x equals 4
to combine with together so let's do
this substitution for that as well
I get 3 lots of 4 squared plus 2 B times
X again which is 4 plus C equals 0 just
like previously I can simplify so 4
squared is 16 3 lots of that is 48 plus
8 B plus C equals 0 now remembering that
B and C what we're trying to find this
is a really good sign because I have two
unknowns but I also have two equations
that I can use to find those unknowns
and just generally speaking if you have
like one unknown a single equation will
be enough to solve that if you have
three unknowns you would need three
equations the more unknowns there are
the more information you need to
determine their values so I've got two
equations two unknowns and so to deal
with them separately I'm going to give
their names what you can see here is
this calculus question is
turned into a simultaneous equations
question which we are well familiar to
deal with but we just haven't had many
questions like that in this context at
this point you're probably honestly fine
but let me just complete the question
now just so you can see me walk through
all the way just in case you need a
reminder about how simultaneous
equations will work
I've got equation one and equation 2
here and here and I can choose a variety
of different ways to combine these
equations to solve them noticing that I
have a plus C here and a plus C here and
probably the easiest thing to do is to
subtract one equation from the other I
can see that the differences you know
there's going to be larger numbers here
than here so I'm going to take equation
2 and then subtract equation 1 from that
so I'm going to write that like so
equation to take away equation 1 you
just got to be careful that you capture
everything so I would write it as 48
plus 8 B plus C there's everything in
equation twos right-hand side on left
hand side I should say and then I'm
going to subtract everything on left in
side of equation one so that's twelve
takeaway for B plus C now on the right
hand side again I'm subtracting the
right-hand side of equation 2 we're
going to subtract equations ones
right-hand side from the equation twos
right-hand side so that ends up being 0
takeaway 0 which is just 0 and now I'm
just going to collect like terms so you
can see here maybe I'll use some colors
to make it a little more obvious I've
got these two numbers here I'm gonna
have these B's here and then lastly I'll
do it in pink I've got these two terms
which both involves C so let's just take
them one at a time
48 take away 12 that's gonna be 36 8b
take away negative 4 be the take away
negative means they're positive so
that's going to be 12 B and then of
course the reason why we did subtraction
of these two equations in the first
place is C take away C just cancels so
don't need to write any of those I've
got a 0 on the right-hand side and from
here I just need to tidy up a little bit
to get my value
of being I've subtracted 36 from both
sides and then I'll divide through by 12
so there we go I have a value for B and
then I'm going to find a place to
substitute that in to find my value for
C I guess either equation will be fine
but I'm gonna go with equation two
because there are less negatives to
worry about so I'm going to substitute
this value that I just found out I'm
gonna substitute B into equation two so
I've got 48 plus eight lots of B which I
now know to be negative three and then I
have that solitary plus C equals zero
over there on the right hand side
okay 48 minus L so 24 plus C so I'm
getting 24 on the left hand side plus C
equals 0 so C looks like negative 24 and
so at this point like they asked me to
find the values of B and C I'm done they
are right here and here other questions
might have asked me to actually just
find the original function so I'd have
to substitute back in and I might say
therefore y equals I think we started
with an X cubed from memory X cubed plus
B which is going to be negative 3x
squared plus C X so that means minus 24
X and then I think there was a plus 5
wasn't there yeah there we go plus 5 is
the function I'm finished so just review
for a second and I'll make sure we knew
what we were doing this is a question
that requires the same knowledge of
differentiation and like a connection
that that has to say Harry points that
we've been using for many questions now
but it just frames it in Reverse so
instead of finding stationary points we
get given stationary points and then we
have to determine information about the
original functions so that means I do a
lot of things that are similar but then
I have to kind of go in Reverse I don't
even find the coordinate of those
stationary points the Y values don't
matter it's just the X values which I
substitute into the derivative which you
can see here when I do that I get a pair
of equations which I need to solve
simultaneously and so then that calls
back on previous knowledge and that
we've developed a long time ago so
hopefully that's helpful and
make sure you read and interpret the
question to say what piece of knowledge
you already have that are relevant like
differentiation like stationary points
meaning the derivative is equal to zero
but then you know don't just go on
autopilot have a think about what the
question is asking you and therefore
reframe the question as necessary and
call on prior knowledge like
simultaneous equations if you need to